un appartement atelier près du
périphérique parisien thomas vue il y
peint des chats son chat monsieur chat
inlassablement l' aventure commencée sur
des murs en 1997 se prolonge sur toile
là par exemple ce que j'essaye de faire
dans ces travaux lancés dans ses
tableaux la c est confronté le côté très
très propre très très cartoon très ligne
claire très à plat avec des taches avait
quelque chose d'un peu plus violent
puisque là on parle de tableau où les
gens vont acheter
il aime bien retrouver un côté un petit
peu sauvage delà de la rue ça leur
permet de sac est assez proche avec le
graffiti ou avec le street art de
posséder dans leur maison un petit parti
petite partie de la rue il ya toujours
cet attrait pour la ville pour le monde
le monde urbain et puis toujours une
aspiration à la liberté voit la liberté
après ça reste toujours le même chat
parce que ce qui ne demande pas ce qu'il
ya une demande
et puis parce que c'est assez agréable
en fait de de reproduire ses formes
simples j'aime toujours bien ce petit
chat et il me rend bien en fait
l'histoire de thomas ville et de
monsieur chat est un conte moderne un
film à rebondissements avec arrestation
révélation célébration la même année
orléans
sur les murs d'orléans et du monde des
chats sont peints à la nuit tombée mars
2007 la police orléanaise arrête de ma
ville en pleine action attraper ses
doigts chars je me suis laissé
interpeller en fait
bon ça se laisser interpeller d'une
certaine façon en fait je officialisait
ma démarche et je jamais me confronter à
la réalité
la société
ça veut dire que la fuite était possible
je me suis laissé attraper de ma ville
sera alors de dix années d'une semi
clandestinité jusque dans sa propre
ville dix ans de chat de petits boulots
de rmi vénissieux kalmthout qui dans et
de la place du coup plus simple pour eux
si des pentures mais ceux-ci des
promenades dans une vie
dom à vue il révélé l'institution ne
voient plus en lui un tagueur
l'empêcheur de voir le gris des murs
mais un artiste un interlocuteur le chat
descendent des toits approche de l'ombre
à la lumière l'auteur glisse le long de
la gouttière
ça m'oblige à être être efficace parce
que c'est quand même mon nom qui signe
ce que je fais et puis surtout ça me
rend plus accessible du coup je peux
rencontrer des gens et du coup avoir des
possibilités de d'autres de travaux ça
ramène une suite suite des propositions
que j'avais pas quand j'étais tout seul
sur mon toit le plus de conséquences
c'est pas c'est pas gratuit voilà c'est
pas gratuit avant c'était gratuit ma
pensée plus gratuit la différence elle
officiellement la ville d'orléans fait
de décembre 2007 le mois du chat fin du
mystère
oui et non le public cherche le créateur
derrière les masques c'est lequel thomas
ville et puis château matteau macha
miroir métaphore thérapie pour kouassi
pourquoi chat on veut savoir de croiser
mais il faut pour l'essai avec l'artiste
pour pas le toucher d'ailleurs en voie
il va pas qu'on touche parlent tous pas
c'est ça la maintenant ils vont un peu
plus qu'on le voit il tolère qu'on le
voit il ya quand même quelque chose qui
a changé est ce que c'était il ya trente
ans je crois c'est une maturité
c'est une autre façon de voir le trait
son travail dans la ville je pense que
c'est une histoire de maturité mais moi
sauvage il est plus domestique pendant
un mois les 10 ans du chat sont
célébrées en grande pompe à orléans
jusqu'au musée des beaux-arts s'il vous
plaît une ambiance des lieux publics et
privés accueille le chat l'exposent
débattent
je fais de la peinture c'est normal qu'à
un moment je rentre dans des lieux de
conservation au caire un marché de l'art
qui s'intéressent au tour il ya
suffisamment de pièces qui ont été fait
puisque je suis pas plus de deux ou
trois mille chaque ont été peints donc
c'est normal qu'au bout d'un moment ça
engendre enfin il n'a pas été fait pour
aller au musée mais je veux dire
pourquoi il irait pas
alors je vais vous présenter un nouvel
artiste il est un petit peu timide le
maire est l'artiste le jour de
l'inauguration sont un peu gauche thomas
côtoient l'institution c'est tout neuf
il se découvre espèce protégée
longtemps il fut considéré comme
nuisible qu'est ce qui fait qu'un jour
les employés municipaux enlève les chats
un jour il ne les enlève plus à l'écouté
et ce qu'ils faisaient qu'ils enlevaient
les chats à une certaine époque c'est
qu'il n'avait pas eu de consignes du
père écope quatre mois je suis arrivé
j'ai dit alors attendez-vous mai face et
surtout plus les chats alors
malheureusement il ya eu encore un effet
d'inertie parce qu'il y en a eu encore
un d'effacer et j'ai dit là maintenant
on arrête je veux qu'on garde des chats
parce que parce que ce personnage est
sympathique il est amusant c'est c'est
l'art de la rue a été de toucher aux
zèbres c'est interdit par la loi
française
l'institution prend conscience du
phénomène chez l'animal et son créateur
sont sollicités pour des projets
événementiels
ce changement de dimension pose question
comment on fait passer quelqu'un qui est
un peintre dans l'espace public pirates
à une situation qu'ils gardent aussi
cette caractéristique la de l'espace
public et y compris femmes âgées c'est
un disque dur et que l'assureur je
disais qu'ils passaient d'un rôle de
pirate un rôle de corsair c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas dans un gros contraste
de méthode mais juste de commanditaires
peut être quelquefois cette année-là
2007 la rencontre de thomas puis les des
acteurs institutionnels marque le temps
de la maturité de part et d'autre cinq
ans ont passé
thomas vue il est monsieur chat ont
quitté le musée d'orléans les toiles
sont exposées dans des galeries mais il
hante toujours les rues
le graff est l'image du chat prospère
sur les murs la légitimité soeur dès
lors la revendication
je suis un citoyen normal c'est à dire
que comme tout le monde je prends ma
responsabilité je prends le droit de
m'exprimer mais je suis responsable des
conséquences de ma peinture est donc
régulièrement
je peux m'expliquer avec la police ils
sont là ils font leur travail je fais
mon travail
des fois ils comprennent des foyers
comprennent pas où on s'explique
il ya débat quoi ce cham me nourrit un
peu comme dans l'histoire du chat botté
qui est le seul héritage de l'enfant du
meunier on peut se dire le meunier en
fait à un chat c'est un petit peu nul
comme héritage mais en fait c'est la
liberté
donc ce chat me donne cette liberté
d'avoir du temps et me ramène un salaire
qui me permet de la dent vivre nourrir
de construire une famille de de voyager
encore plus d'acheter du matériel de
d'aider d'autres personnes et des autres
artistes
ce chat nourricier peut-être faudrait-il
préciser qu'il n'en a pas toujours été
ainsi
il ya 15 ans thomas faisait ses
expériences défiant les interdits les
lois de la pesanteur aussi les toits
d'orléans des villes de province des
capitales européennes sont ses premiers
terrains de jeu avant paris en 2000 je
les peins au sol et ils sont effacés
donc je m'intéresse aux
à la hauteur mais par contre quand je
commence à monter je me rends pas
forcément compte que je vais découvrir
un autre univers
enfin c'est un univers particulier que
je connaissais pas petit mari qui m'a
fasciné se trouve face vraiment à une
ville qui devient toute plate et qui est
tout en inde
et quand j allais moi c'était au moment
où les villes étaient endormis donc en
plus j'ai l'impression d'être le dernier
homme éveillé enfin je suis partie des
derniers qui sont réveillés alors que
tout le monde mais en a remis un peu m
du monde aussi domine je peux être un
petit peu je me fais mes petits films
les années 2000 l'europe l'asie
l'amérique
l'animal et son créateur voyage pourrait
changer voire commencer ailleurs thomas
ville commence à être attendus demandé
en 2004 un événement inattendu à
amplifier l'aura du chat chris marker la
piste et sans connaître son auteur et en
a fait un documentaire chat perché à
thomas ville qui n'avait rien demandé
l'intellectuel référence du cinéma et de
l'art et son film ouvriront les portes
de beaubourg le centre d'art
contemporain parisien le chat dollars
cela ne fait plus de doute
désormais on est dans l'arc et dans la
rue posées aux yeux de tout le monde et
qui est une image en commun fait l'idée
c'est ça c'est que deux personnes qui se
connaissent pas si regarde le même
tableau avec une émotion qui est pas
forcément la même ils ont déjà un nous
sommes des changes je pense que le chat
pour thomas était aussi au début sa
monnaie car sa manière de rentrer en
communication avec les autres pour une
personne ou les autres contacts sont
difficiles on voit que les signes qui
ont droit à une espèce de visibilité
mondiale
c'est quoi c'est coca cola c'est nike
c'est jésus christ et lénine et c'est
quand on regarde bien les cils sont des
signes d'injonction des signes de
règlement des signes positifs des signes
économiques etc
et là je pense que balancer comme ça une
image une image sauf pause par là même
la réflexion sur le signe je veux dire
le signe que l'on voit qu est ce qu un
signe dans l'espace que vous qu'est ce
que ça veut dire et ses rangs plusieurs
centaines de cygnes et dessiné par
thomas ville épaulé par un collectif une
association le félin feder et interroge
toujours en 2007 en période de campagne
municipale
orléans se demande si le chat est de
droite ou de gauche ligne claire réponse
claire monsieur chat est souvent appelé
pour animer des ateliers auprès de
personnes fragilisées ou handicapées ici
à l'institut sereine
une structure qui accueille des enfants
en rupture familiale et sociale
il est là l'engagement de thomas vue
c'est de la sensation en fait c'est des
regards c'est ma tasse la satisfaction
de voir un enfant qui a les yeux qui
s'illuminent qui prend de la confiance
en lui ou en elle j'ai toutes des
petites choses comme ça qui sont
difficilement quantifiables en fait et
qui font évoluer les choses vont évoluer
la société petit à petit je pense que
c'est là la place des artistes en fête
c'est dans le quotidien et dans les
petites choses qui font les grandes
petit à petit ce chat donné aux enfants
c'est un retour à l'envoyeur puisque au
commencement le chat et le dessin naïf
d'une petite fille donné à thomas il
travaillera le graphisme et aura l'idée
de proposer cette image à notre regard
avec le désir d'embellir la ville et le
quotidien la force du chat c'est qu'on
peut l'intellectualiser et qu'il trouve
sa place dans un dessin d'enfant tout en
même temps ils nous regardent tous
parlent à chacun ce que les gens
comprennent pas c'est que c'est un
personnage à part entière alors je suis
paraître pour un fou de dire ça mais
c'est vrai il a sa propre vie au travers
des autres ce chat il a sa propre vie
c'est à dire entre - comment je le
perçois c'est de la peinture sur des
bouts de carton sur des choses comme ça
mais finalement le regard que me renvoie
les
les autres personnes c'est comme si
c'était un autre personnage je sais pas
comment dire ça comme un avatar en fait
quelque chose qui me dépasse dépassés se
dépasser la fin de la clandestinité la
grande exposition médiatique de 2007
n'ayant pas eu la peau du chat thomas
vue il s'interroge à haute voix pourquoi
j'aurais pas le droit d'essayer même des
coups marketing pour copains
enfin oui je suis pas apprécié le temps
qui le dira et puis même entre ce qu'on
veut faire ce qu'on arrive à faire et ce
qu'il reste dans le temps il ya
tellement de données que je sais pas je
sais pas ce que sera le fleuve en 50 ans
et peut-être que quand je serai mort
cela n'existera plus peut-être que du
coup ça continuera
c'est pour ça que je le donne aux gens
et que j'essaye de le mettre un maximum
dans la dans la vie des gens pourquoi
pas un coup de marketing s'interrogeait
thomas ville en 2007
aujourd'hui le chat de thomas est une
marque qu'est ce qu'il ya avant d'en
fait alors des petites peluches des sacs
à dos des coques de téléphones portables
des brochures des savonnettes
ce chat offertes au regard du passant et
depuis peu un produits dérivés
commercialisés en asie pour l'instant
par un ami coréen du créateur est
magnifique publication fabriqués en
europe
face à cette apparente contradiction
l'entretien mise au point s'impose 27
euros ce qui m'amuse c'est de peindre
ces deux peintres dans la rue et que les
gens soient contents
ce qui m'amuse aussi dans ses produits
c'est de me dire que pour 5 10 balles
des gens peuvent avoir un monsieur chat
alors que les tableaux deviennent de
plus en plus cher parce que c'est le
principe de l'art il faut créer de la
rareté créer des produits élitistes et
donc des produits
cher alors que les produits dérivés
permettent de se faire plaisir pour je
sais pas pour 15 euros
et ça ça m'amuse c'est un petit peu à
l'image de notre monde qui est tenu par
des grandes industries tout et produits
de consommation donc mon chat et j'ai
poussé un peu mon chat pour ce que
j'étais curieux pour aller un peu dans
cet univers là après je sais pas du tout
où ça s'arrêtera et je ne sais pas du
tout si ça va pas le le tuer ou jeu j'en
sais rien non je suis fier quoi après en
france on a un problème avec l'argent
avec le commerce mais je veux dire y'a
rien de malhonnête derrière ça après
j'avoue je contrôle pas tout donc je
vais pas faire semblant de dire ah oui
c'est fabriqué en produits recyclés
patati patata
mais ça viendra il se démultiplie à
telle échelle que peut-être que le chat
va bouffer mickey quoi ça c'est plutôt
les goûts